i come to you today with some delightful
news sarah palin has lost to a democrat
in alaska and it is absolutely fantastic
not only in so far as it's yet another
humiliation for sarah palin and she
really deserves a little dose of
humiliation but it also does not look
good for republicans if the argument you
want to be making is they are inevitably
poised to crush democrats in november
now in the next story we're going to
look at the latest numbers in terms of
the forecasts in the house and in the
senate but one of the things that some
have been arguing is not reflected in
those forecasts today
is a certain momentum a certain
undefined and as of now unquantified
shift
towards democrats not yet reflected in
the polling and the sarah palin loss in
alaska is a really really big deal so
let's talk about it democrat peltola
beats palin in alaska's special election
upset
reports politico
now remember
sarah palin was once the governor of
alaska alaska is a red state
sarah palin is a republican and she is a
very well-known republican in alaska and
yet
as joseph gedion writes
democrat mary paltola has defeated
republican sarah palin in the special
election for alaska's vacant house seat
a big upset over the former governor in
the state's first election under ranked
choice voting peltola is a former state
legislator who will become alaska's
first indigenous member of congress
defeated a special election field that
included palin and another republican
nick begich iii
the democrat finished first in the
initial tally and then won enough second
choice votes from begich's supporters to
see off palin who was endorsed by trump
so this is this is so good in so many
different ways it's a poetic justice of
many types number one
sarah palin republican
in a republican state loses to a
democrat that's very interesting number
two sarah palin is a known republican
who was the late john mccain's running
mate in 2008 for vice president sort of
started dum-dum republican politics
which of course trump then blew out of
the water like palin was nothing
compared to what trump ultimately was
but still was sort of the start of that
cartoonish direction for republicans and
also it is another endorsement failure
for donald trump now you might be saying
david sir
are they already calling fraud and the
answer is yes they are if you look at
truth social you will see all sorts of
people saying it was obviously
fraudulent it was obviously stolen
and of course there is no evidence of
that whatsoever and sarah palin managing
to lose alaska is one of the funniest
and most entertaining political moments
that i have seen in a while it's really
a humiliation and it is one of these
this is a seat
that republicans have held for decades
in a state that hasn't voted for a
democrat for president since lbj like
that's i know that we have this accurate
understanding and story about alaska
that alaska republicans are a little bit
different and they are it's sort of like
vermont democrats are a little bit
different vermont democrats uh are more
in favor of gun ownership and okay
absolutely fine
but if vermont voted for trump it would
still be a really big deal and similarly
to see alaska opt not to vote for their
own former governor and vote instead for
a woman who's going to be the first
indigenous member of the house from
alaska ever
it's absolutely fantastic and we can
also point to the importance of ranked
choice voting in this race uh the first
such election under ranked choice voting
in alaska just a lot of really great
things
going on here a couple other notes from
the politico article
um
the defeat for palin closes the door on
an immediate political comeback but
remember she's also on the ballot in
november
where the winner will get a full
two-year term this is just a special
election because of the open seat sarah
palin is still in the fight in november
and that's that's another element to
this in the um
once the ranked choice tallies were
applied mary potola came away with 51
and a half percent of the vote palin had
48 and a half so that's about a
three-point margin which in that race
worked out to about
5700 or so votes if my 5 300 or so votes
if my math
serves me so the big story here is
democratic over performance over
performance and this article in politico
talks about that
and it is a really important thing we
had the michigan example which i told
you about last week
again in which running on the issue of
women's rights abortion rights family
planning rights call it whatever you
want
we saw another democratic upset and so
this is why
it could be argued and it's a predictive
argument we won't know until november it
could be argued and some are arguing and
i would to some degree argue this very
same thing
that the official polling numbers right
now particularly for the house don't
necessarily reflect the momentum and the
strength of the democratic party and
democratic enthusiasm now tonight
president joe biden is going to address
the nation from philadelphia
sort of riding high buoyed as i like to
say by his recent legislative
accomplishments and spiking approval
rating and joe biden is going to make
the case for voting for democrats in
november now just
uh eight weeks away i guess we are
roughly eight eight and a half weeks
away that will be interesting to see but
let's now discuss where the numbers are
today in looking at november
one of our long time sponsors splendid
spoon is giving you fifty dollars off as
many of you know i am not vegetarian but
i think eating plant-based
is a great thing and i do more of it
consciously
splendid spoon takes the work out of
eating plant-based by delivering
ready-to-eat plant-based meals smoothies
and juices right to your door splendid
spoon fits into my day easily the meals
are in my fridge put them on the
stovetop or in the microwave and i've
got a great fresh plant-based meal in a
few minutes it saves me time which is
really useful right now whether you're
vegan or you just want to add an easy
delicious way to have more plants in
your diet splendid spoon is a great way
to go
there are great dishes like creamy
mushroom and spinach noodles coconut
curry cauliflower tikka soup that's one
of my favorites tons of choices the menu
rotates constantly i've tried a lot of
different meal subscription services
splendid spoon is great on both taste
and quality they pack so much flavor
into the dishes they taste freshly
cooked splendid spoons smoothies are
awesome when i'm on the go and you'll
get 50 off your first week when you
subscribe at
splendidspoon.com pacman the link is
down below